did you take anything from the harry
potter set technically no
despite being huge celebrities the harry
potter actors didn't always get
everything they wanted especially when
it came to set props
there were major rules the cast had to
follow that prohibited them from taking
home
any props and left some cast members
extremely embarrassed when they were
caught
but there was still a few magical
trinkets that managed to find their way
past
the studio gates including a flying car
i haven't stolen anything
don't lie alan rickman may have been one
of the most
respected actors in the uk but that
didn't stop his harry potter co-star zoe
wanamaker
also known as madame hooch from calling
him out
alongside zoe allen used his sneaky
slytherin skills to swipe some of
harry's hogwarts letters that we see
in the philosopher's stone there were
lots of these little letters that the
owl brings to harry
rickman and i started to nick some of
them these props weren't just
memorabilia for alan either
zoe says he ended up selling one of the
letters in los angeles for 25 000
allen didn't just stop at the letters
either he was given permission to keep
snape's one
at the end of the franchise but that
didn't seem like enough for him
rumors circulated that he also stole
snape's frock that he wore
in all eight movies but when he was
asked about it all he could say was
i don't think i dare tell you the answer
to that
we think we know what that means that's
better isn't it
of course being the chosen one even
off-screen came with some perks
despite the no taking props rule daniel
radcliffe was given a pair of harry's
glasses from the first and last film
he still has them to this day but admits
they aren't exactly
usable the ones from the first film are
absolutely
tiny now but they are very sweet they
are all lensless as well there was
rarely ever any glass in the actual
glasses
because of filming problems with
reflections i've got a prosthetic arm
that was um that was molded for me in
the scene where harry like lost all the
bones in his
however just because he was gifted a
prop doesn't mean he didn't partake in
his own fair share of prop swiping
he said he had the weirdest prop hidden
up in his parents attic
the prosthetic arm he used while filming
the chamber of secrets quidditch scene
so i've got like big floppy arms in my
attic he also managed to grab the mold
of his face that the makeup department
used for the first few films
[Music]
emma watson was a little more
level-headed with the props she stole
from the set
in fact she said she wanted to make sure
what she took represented her time as a
hogwarts student
i took my wand i took my time turner and
i took a cloak
that settles it emma really is a
real-life hermione
to ronald bilius weasley i leave my
illuminator just like ron rupert grint
ended up with dumbledore's deluminator
while the deluminator was given to him
rupert ended up stealing the number four
private drive sign from the dursley
house listen to him confess to what he
did
and i also took um the number of privet
drive
considering ron didn't spend very much
time at the dursley household you
wouldn't think the privet drive sign
would be something rupert would take
but he just couldn't resist
who wants me to open it it's too bad
rupert wasn't given the deluminator
before they wrapped the franchise maybe
it could have helped him out when he
tried to steal the dragon egg from the
goblet of fire
but instead he attempted to get it out
of the studio using a pillowcase but
ultimately got caught i took the golden
egg that was in the fourth film
a dragon egg apparently it was worth a
few thousand dollars
i put it in a pillowcase it was with
james oliver
it was a joint effort but they tracked
it down and got it off us
ivana lynch may not have ended up
stealing anything from the harry potter
set but it wasn't for a lack of effort
while filming she asked the filmmakers
if she would be able to take the cast of
her foot they had molded while filming
they made molds of my feet for one scene
even though we didn't end up using them
and i asked for them and they wouldn't
let me have them on the bright side
though she was given some fox feathers
in order to make the earrings she wore
to the order of the phoenix premiere
let's have a bit of fun shall we
ironically matthew lewis ended up
swiping one of the things he hated the
most from the films his fake
teeth my parents have this weird sort of
shrine for me and the teeth are in there
although it's nice to have the memory he
did admit it was kind of gross
one thing is for sure his teeth shrine
must be one heck of a conversation
starter at family dinners
he also kept the prosthetic ears he wore
in chamber of secrets
funny that paper of yours a couple
nights ago i could have sworn i saw
picture me
jason isaacs may have had the most
embarrassing experience of them all
while filming he asked
director david yates if it would be okay
if he took a copy of the daily prophet
he was given the all clear but when he
got to the studio gate it was a
different story
i put it in my bag and when i got to the
gates they said david said can he have
it back
it was so embarrassing jason says he
blames alan's swiping of gringotts coins
during the early films as the reason why
the studio became so strict
it was very difficult to steal things
because alan god love him
god rest his soul he nicked all of the
gringotts coins on the very first day he
did goblet of fire
and swiped in and out like a supermarket
and who might you be young
man never long bottom besides the
prosthetics matthew lewis was also given
a pardon gift in the form of a prop
he was given neville's entire deathly
hallows costume
including the wand but he can't reveal
exactly who gave it to him um
i've got my entire costume from the
final
movie i won't say who did it because
that they might be able to figure it out
but someone came into my dressing room
at the end of the day
on the last day and was like do you want
this and i said yes i said put it in
your bag right now
and i will leave the room and i said
okay so
i i uh i i guess i stole that
matthew lewis may be the actor who
walked away with the most from the films
while this next prop he stole may seem a
little strange it's hard to believe he
even pulled it off
while filming the goblet of fire he took
a piece from the triwizard tournament
maze
little did we know that while the
tri-wizard champions were busy fighting
voldemort matthew lewis
was looking for a piece of the
tournament he could keep to himself
we mentioned zoe wanamaker was alan
rickman's co-conspirator in stealing
hogwarts letters but she also walked
away with a few items herself
she managed to swipe t-shirts and a
stunt person hat that she
wore while doing her own stunts while
she said she still does have some of the
letters
she hasn't mentioned whether or not she
sold a few like her pal alan
the harry potter cast has been adamant
that stealing wands from the set was
near impossible but for actor kieran
hines it was the easiest part of playing
aberforth
he claims he stole more than three dozen
wands from the harry potter set as well
as a pair of purple socks
it may seem a little bit morbid but
oliver phelps says he was able to steal
his prosthetic ear from deathly hallows
and even still has it framed in his home
because there were so many he just put
it on a napkin after filming one night
and left set
it may be just an ear but ivana lynch
got pretty jealous when she found out he
got to take home
his prosthetic and she wasn't allowed to
keep hers
apparently people have been hiding them
that's awful
oh it's all good fun this cast was on
the set of films that were full of some
of the best props the film industry
could offer
but couldn't touch any of it that had to
have been rough
it's good to know that the majority of
the cast were able to take something to
help remember their time on harry potter
in the end
some of course larger than others
according to rupert he managed to get
his hands on the flying car from the
philosopher's stone
you're not alone if you're trying to
figure out how exactly
that happened don't worry though it's
just collecting dust in his garage
he rents it out to museums and exhibits
for the film
which prop would you have tried to steal
from the set thanks for watching